so what I'm going to talk about today is
part of a work in progress so I would
really love to have your feedback I'm
working on a book now and I think about
the book is about what sort of social
science in the digital age so I see a
sort of two very distinct communities I
see social scientists doing cool stuff
but they could really benefit from
seeing what data scientists are doing
and I see data scientists doing cool
stuff but they could really benefit from
seeing what social scientists are doing
so this book is about sort of trying to
bring together the ideas of these two
communities so I see that also one
challenge with doing a project like this
is that you're speaking to a mixed
audience and I see here there's also
some mixed audience to some social
science this year and some computer
science this year so if I seem to be be
laboring some point that you think is
totally obvious that's because my guess
is it's not obvious to the other
community and if their stuff that using
is really interesting or important that
you think I'm leaving out definitely
feel free to jump in okay so one of the
questions that I think must be addressed
before you work on a book project such
as this is one that a lot of my
colleagues asked me well you know in
secret they're like hey Matt by the way
isn't this big data stuff just a fad and
the answer is definitely no so I think
the word big data is absolutely a fab
and it looks very fab like but what this
actually represents it's not a fad it's
a fundamental change in the world so in
sociology in particular and in general
academic field certain things become
popular and then unlike in sociology for
a while you know there was like a
Marxist turn and then everyone started
having a Marxist kind of approach and
then people started becoming neova
burien and then like there are these
sort of academic fads but those are fads
because they're driven by sort of
discussions happening within the field
and what I see is really different about
big data for lack of
better word is it's not has nothing to
do with what sociologists or social
sciences are talking about it has to do
with a fundamental change in the world
and that fundamental change the change
from the analog to the digital is
something that is happening has happened
and it's not going to go away and
progress will continue very quickly in
this dimension and so our choice is
really to take advantage of that
progress or be left behind but I do
think there are kind of this concern
about fads i think is beautifully
captured by this model which some of you
may have seen it's called the hype cycle
so it's used to understand when a new
technology enters the system how people
think about it so here the x-axis here
is the time and the y-axis is the
visibility so initially things come in
and then all of a sudden everyone thinks
oh my god this is going to be the
greatest thing ever and then people are
like oh no this is totally terrible and
then eventually like the technology
becomes normalized part of everyday life
and so I think for different people are
in different parts of this curve in the
big data space now so I think maybe in
this room maybe more people are here or
maybe there I don't know where everyone
is here but one of the goals of my book
is to really sort of damp this down a
lot so pull down that that peak push up
that trough and then get to the part
where this is just a normal way of doing
social science so now most of the to set
up really why I think what I'm going to
talk about is important I want to
contrast it with most of what I see as
computational social science now so this
is a picture of footprints on the beach
and I think most of the data that people
are analyzing now about social behavior
is this kind of footprints or digital
exhaust so this is data that's generated
as a byproduct of everyday life and
researchers have expended a lot of
energy trying to get this data from
companies or scraping it from the web
and then doing lots of analysis with it
so most of
computational social science work is
this kind of work and the metaphor that
people use about this is they say oh
this is like the microscope or this is
like the telescope and I think that's
totally the wrong metaphor so even
though this data is shiny and new the
better metaphor is that this data is
relics this is like the like archaeology
basically we have a bunch of junk not
junk I mean sure this is very nice pot
we have a bunch of stuff that has
basically been left behind and so were
you to go to an archaeological dig and
work with pottery shards a lot of
questions would come up like why is this
why did some things get saved and not
other things what can we infer from the
shape of this pot about these people's
attitudes or opinions so like in a lot
of ways these pottery shards are not the
strongest form of evidence that we can
have about how a society works like what
we would really like to be able to do is
go and collect the data that we want not
just be stuck with the data that we have
and so this is sort of the main argument
of the book so there's going to be seven
chapters the main chapters are these
four hear about different ways that
researchers and participants can
interact how the data is collected that
I think is the main way to think about
all these different things that are
happening rather than thinking about oh
this is like Twitter data and this is
facebook data and this is google data
that is a very time specific way of
thinking and i think that there are sort
of more general and kind of timeless
ways of thinking so that when some new
platform emerges we don't want to go
through the same like we've spent a lot
of time we as a community have spent a
lot of time trying to learn from Twitter
data and we've stepped in some potholes
during that process and like we don't
want to have to do that every time some
new platform emerges and we know that
new platforms will emerge new sources of
data will emerge that is something we
can predict with high confidence and so
if we want to learn from those things
quickly
without repeating all those same
mistakes we need to abstract away and
have some more general principles and so
in my mind the way of thinking about
these this thing about how the data is
collected so most of the data is this
observed data where we basically just
watch people and see what they do and
then the book is really an argument that
you want to move down this list you want
to have more and more interaction with
the participant more and more control
over the data you're collecting so then
you can sort of ask people questions
this is like surveys you can do
experiments or you can do mass
collaboration so as you go down this
list it gets harder and harder to do I
think but the benefits can be greater
and so in my own work I've so what I'm
going to talk about today is
collaborating so in my own work I've
done some previous stuff on new forms of
surveys this is Michael mentioned the
wiki service and I've done some stuff on
new forms of experiments this is like
the music experiment on my music
experiment and I have not done as much
about new forms of collaborating but to
me this is the most exciting because
this is to me offers the greatest
possible improvement over what we're
doing now but it also seems the hardest
so I'm really stumped about how one
would go about doing this which is part
of the reason I'm excited to be here so
now I'm going to sort of walk through
how I think about this space what I
think are the problems and in general
I'll sort of offer a topology that I
think is useful for social science and
then I'll give an example in that space
that that you might be familiar with and
then I'll give some examples from social
science that you might not be familiar
with and also the idea is that in social
science now the bar it there's so much
skepticism about this like if you if I
seem to be overly defensive and overly
pessimistic that's because when i talk
to social scientists about doing these
kinds of mass collaborations they are
very very very skeptical so the kinds of
claims i'm going to try to make here i
think are very very modest and that sort
of explains the tone tone is sort of
where i'm coming from ok so for me a
really inspirational example is
wikipedia i just love wikipedia
is so cool this group of distributed
volunteers around the world has produced
this amazing intellectual product and it
wasn't new knowledge that was really
necessary for Wikipedia to form it was a
new form of collaboration so Wikipedia
allowed people to share and aggregate
the knowledge they had in a new way and
it produced this beautiful thing and so
one of the things I see a lot of these
digital age tools enabling is new forms
of collaboration so now that we you know
we already collaborate on our research
right we work with our peers we work
with advisors we work with colleagues
there is already collaboration and
research but now we can collaborate in
much different ways at much different
scales so can we use the tools of the
digital age to enable new forms of mass
collaboration to solve scientific
problems so here's how I think about
chopping up this space so I think that
you can use mass collaboration for data
analysis or for data collection and then
within data analysis I think you can
either specify a clear task and this
leads the human computation style work
you can specify a goal and this leads to
more open call style work and you can
also just have straight up data
collection and so from my perspective as
an outsider in this space I see lots of
work happening in this part of the space
like how can we do more M Turk style
stuff and I think there's a lot of
opportunities here to do different kinds
of things and I was actually really
excited to hear that lots of the people
here in the HCI group are working on
moving into these other parts of this
space because I think these are the
parts of the space that are potentially
well more interesting to me as a social
scientist like these are the things that
I would really like to be able to do and
I don't really know how to do them so
let me know so I'm going to sort of walk
through each of these categories and I
should again say if you have any
questions or comments feel free to jump
in yeah
the problem solving rather than just
date that collection that also should be
in your space on the collaboration right
yeah so I would say that I would problem
solving I would sort of call put in with
data analysis and data collection and so
one other thing about this topology
someone asked me like oh like where did
this come from like what principles lead
you to this topology and there are no
principles that lead to this this is
just like my reading of this and
thinking about it and thinking about it
in a way that I hope will be useful to
social scientists so I should also say
that part of the reason I think I ended
up in this space this way is that these
sort of map on two ways that social
scientists already think about
collaboration so human computation is a
little bit like hiring a bunch of
research assistants open call is a
little bit like talking to skilled
experts or get soliciting ideas from
skilled experts and distributed data
collection is something that we already
do when we like hire a survey firm so we
would pay people to go out and interview
other people and give us the data what
if we could sort of do that without
paying people through a firm so I think
these sort of implicitly map onto things
that social scientists are doing already
okay so human computation so I think the
one of the my favorite examples of this
is Galaxy Zoo just a show of hands how
many people have liked seeing Galaxy Zoo
okay good okay about half so basically
astronomers are interested in galaxies
and I'm going to totally butcher
everything about galaxies because I'm
not an astronomer but as a crude
approximation for the purposes of this
talk there's two main kinds of galaxies
there are elliptical galaxies and there
are spiral galaxies and galaxies also
have different colors red and blue and
so roughly they wanted to know something
about the prevalence of red elliptical
galaxies and red spiral get like the
relationship between color and shape and
so it turned out so that's the problem
and they have picture of a bunch of
galaxies that were taken by
telescopes so at the time it was very
hard for to train a machine this is
around 2007 I was hard to train a
machine learning classifier to
distinguish between spirals and
ellipticals so you needed to do this by
hand so a graduate student named Kevin
Schwantz key worked for seven 12-hour
days and classified fifty thousand
galaxies it's a lot of work they wrote
this nice paper about it but the problem
is that this was only five percent of
the galaxies that they had photographed
and it also turns out that now we knew
our satellites capture on the order of
10 billion of these images so this
approach is not going to work need to
scale it up more so kevin and chris linn
thought and some other people created
this website Galaxy Zoo where anyone in
the world could come and classify
galaxies and so the volunteers had a
very short training so only a couple of
minutes and then they had to pass a
simple quiz and then they were
astronomers that's it they didn't need
to go get a PhD from Stanford just this
five-minute training they could classify
as many or as few galaxies as they
wanted and then much of the recruitment
happened through the media it didn't
happen through Turk or anything like
that this was volunteers who were coming
to participate in a scientific project
to help further the goals of astronomy
so what happened so over the course of a
couple of months they had four times ten
to the seven forty million
classifications and the distribution of
classifications per participant is
something that you would probably be
very accustomed to seeing which is not
something that social scientists are
used to seeing but you have a small
number of people who are contributing a
very large number of classifications and
a lot of people who are contributing a
few classification so there's very
unequal amounts of information
contributed per person so then you have
all these 40 million classifications
from a bunch of people how do you
put them together and get one consensus
classification so there's sort of three
main steps and this will be familiar to
people who have done these kind of human
computing projects so first you clean
the data so they get rid of things that
appear to be people trying to manipulate
the system like people have classified
the same galaxy many many times then
they D by us this dividing step is
really important so if you averaged
together a bunch of contributions that
only can remove random noise and it
doesn't deal with systematic biases so
for example it turns out that far away
spiral galaxies look like elliptical
galaxies and so there is this bias built
in to the way that people do these
classifications and these r astronomers
were very sensitive to these biases and
they built studies into the original
Galaxy Zoo to measure these biases so
then they did this the biasing step and
then they did a combining step where
they sort of essentially did a weighted
average where you've seen probably
things like this before they tried to
give more way to the people who seem to
be better classifiers so you put all
this together and the quality of the
classifications that come from this
crowd process are comparable to those
that come from the astronomers but there
are 10 times bigger and this enables
them to do new science this is the extra
part that I think is really important
this enables them to do new science so
it enabled them to understand this
relationship between galaxies and it's
led to another a number of other sort of
scientific advances so I like this that
here this human computation goes
directly into the service of some
scientific problem and so the general
recipes you take this big problem you
split it up into lots of little problems
then you apply some human work on each
one independently and then you combine
them all together use it with this D
biasing and cleaning and some kind of
weighted averaging so how could you use
this same split apply and combine recipe
for a social science kind of problem so
give you an example now so some first
some background so political parties
they publish manifestos during elections
so these are documents that sort of lay
out
what are the goals of the party during
that particular election and there's
something called the manifesto project
which is a collaboration of political
scientists mostly in Europe and they
have hand coded a 4,000 of these
manifestos from nearly 50 countries so
here's an example of what a piece of one
of these looks like so this is from the
labor party manifesto from the UK from
2010 millions of people are working in
our public services and body the best
values of Britain helping to empower
people in zone zone so on so that's the
kind of text that they're working with
and then they have these experts code
this to assess the political positions
that are being taken by the party so
imagine if you were a political
scientist and you wanted to understand
like what's the dynamics of competition
between political parties and how does
that differ across countries in Europe
that's the kind of question that you
might ask and these manifestos are very
valuable data to answer that question
but it's very difficult to extract the
kinds of signal that you want from this
kind of text and so the way they had
done it in the past is with these
experts doing the coding so in this way
this is like the picture of the galaxy
in some sense that needs some human work
done to it so then this more recent
paper by Binoy and colleagues they say
let's try to turn this into a human
computation system rather than giving it
to the experts will give it to a bunch
of volunteers so they do this and they
code up the economic positions of these
platforms and the social positions and
the expert coding and the crowd coding
match so what I love about this paper
though is that this is not the end of
the paper this is the beginning of the
paper so first they show okay we can
turn this over to the crowd and then
they say but what extra does this give
us and so they argue that this new
process is not just cheaper or faster
they argued it's actually better and so
this is the thing that I see I wish more
human computation where cuz
sort of express this more clearly about
how it's better not just cheaper faster
I like cheaper and faster I'm all for
that but like I think better is also
cool too and so like one of the ways
that they argue their human computation
thing is better is they say it's more
reproducible and so by that what they
mean is ideally you would take the
rawest form of data you have and all the
way to your final scientific conclusion
and be able to reproduce that entire
pipeline it that is a goal and if you're
using expert coatings from the manifesto
project you can't do that because the
raws data is the text and you don't have
that anymore you can't access that
directly all you start with is the
expert coding and how do we know how
good this expert coding is that's
actually there's actually a lot of
debate about that and how could that be
improved it's some kind of a mess so
with this crowd with this sort of crowd
based approach that they actually do an
analysis and then two months later they
do the exact same thing and they get the
same result and to me that's a very
powerful kind of argument for why and
it's actually super easy like all your
all this stuff that you can do in a
human computation system it's not that
hard to just do it again a month later
and show you get the same thing and it's
a nice added check about the quality of
your system so they say not only is this
cheaper than doing it with experts it's
actually more reproducible and then it
gets us from the raw data to the final
output and it's also more flexible so
they then they demonstrate one issue
that is becoming increasingly of
interest to political scientist is
policies about immigration and when this
coding scheme was developed by the
experts it was in the mid-80s and
immigration was not a major issue in
Europe and so none of these manifestos
had been coded for positions about
immigration and so they said well it
would be virtually impossible for us to
go back to all these experts and recode
all these things about immigration but
our system is like really flexible and
so we can customize it to the kinds of
data that we want to collect and then
they collected the data about
immigration that they cared about and so
I guess another way of saying this is
another way that's you
you can sort of say it's cheaper and
faster that also means it's more easily
tailored to the kinds of problems that
you care about and so that can lead to
better data and better sign so this
paper is impressed and I really like it
okay so that guess the kind of claims
yet to participate that's a good
question so i did not say this one uses
crowd flower so this one is money Galaxy
Zoo is a you know love of science
excitement I'll talk a little bit more
about motivation at the end but I do
think that's like the biggest problem
like it's pairing people who want to do
stuff or to some scientifically
meaningful task and that's I think still
more of an art I don't know how I mean
that's why I don't know I mean so like
what I would say is people do it and
like we can try to figure out why they
do it exactly and why they don't do it
but I find that those things are very
hard for people to are like how would
you figure out why people do Wikipedia
you could ask them but is that even
really going to be helpful so that's
part of the reason that I like a lot of
this talk is just examples because I
feel like in this kind of setting where
it's not really clear what's going on
like an example based approach is really
helpful I mean people do Wikipedia why
do they do it I don't know yeah you were
seeing that the very few number of
people contribute the most yes um what
is the quality of their contribution
compares to the majority of the people
yes that actually a good very good
question and so it turns out to be the
case in some of these projects but not
all of them that the people who
contribute the most are the highest
quality workers so the fact that most of
the data is contributed by a small
number of people is actually a good
thing because those are the highest
quality workers but this issue of worker
quality I'm glad you brought that up so
I think a lot of social scientists are I
used to I don't know if your social
scientists or not yeah
so I could I thought I could tell by
your question so a lot of social
scientists who have hired research
assistants before they're like man it's
hard to work with research assistants
like Stanford undergraduates very smart
very hard working heavily screened
population like these should be the and
if you try to hire them as research
assistants it's going to be hard and
you're going to have to do a lot of
quality control and it seems like how
could you if Stanford undergraduates are
so hard to work with how could you
possibly like just have anyone in the
world do it but I think the difference
is that quality control and a lot of
these projects comes through redundancy
not through skill so there were 40
classifications per galaxy and like if
you had that level of redundancy with
your research assistants you wouldn't
need to be as careful about what each
one of them is doing so right you need
to be super careful because there is no
redundancy and so I think like one way
to think about it is like quality
through redundancy yeah yeah it's not
too that it's entirely a terminus kick
process there were a number of
collectively editable encyclopedias at
the same time that he was created in all
which fans so the motivations are still
there like seeing something wrong on the
internet is a very strong motivator to
fix it for example but it's not not
enough there's a certain amount yeah but
I think we don't know I mean I think
there's I mean just as you get an HR
like the news about experiment and it's
like there is some amount of it that
business is makes it feasible that it
might succeed and beyond that you know
if it does succeed you can say something
about the processes that would have
generated that but if it doesn't succeed
you can't guarantee that it wouldn't
have happened get away around I look
also at reddit there's Eric over has a
great paper where he shows that you know
basically stuck gets reposted all the
time and it's almost random which one of
them ends up making the cut page like
it's just path dependence who are the
first few people and do they get into it
as a building community yeah so I wanna
say one more thing about participation
because I think this is something that
also a lot of people think about I took
a lot of people start with themselves
and then try to build out there like Oh
would I go online and classify these
galaxies no I wouldn't do that I'm
really busy like I don't have time to do
that and then they're like well what my
friends do that no I don't think they
would either so no one's going to do
that so they start with themselves and
build out but that's the wrong way to
think about it I think the right way to
think about its think of the entire set
of people connected to the Internet and
then if one in a billion of these people
do it your project will be a failure if
one in a million of these people do it
it could be a success and like we have
to acknowledge that it's very hard for
us to anticipate the difference between
one and a million and a one-in-a-billion
and so it's really hard to know ahead of
time whether it's going to work or not
that if you're not using one of these
micro task platforms I think that's one
of the problems is and it's also takes a
while before you fail so you might
invest a lot of time building one of
these things and then no one shows up
and you failed that's really bad so I
don't really know how to make it easier
to fail faster or somehow make it easier
to anticipate whether it will be
successful ok ok so there's some very
simple claims here that I want to make
human computation can be used for real
research like Galaxy Zoo that was about
really advancing astronomy they made
real advances in astronomy from that
data and then also human computation can
produce better data not just cheaper
data ok
so now I want to move on to open
contests and so I want to talk briefly
about the netflix prize and some
specific aspects of the netflix process
i think make it really really cool so
netflix recommends movies to you these
by the way are not my recommend these
are this is something i took off the
internet like I I mean I might like I've
never seen 300 but I might like it so
basically what Netflix does is they take
the ratings that you've given to movies
and then they try to guess what ratings
you will give to other movies based on
the rating patterns of yourself and
others and so they want to it's really
important to them to be able to predict
what movies you like and they launched
the system around 2000 and then they
refined it over the course of about six
years and it got better and better and
better and eventually they kind of got
stuck it wasn't getting any better and
that worked really hard on it but they
knew there were some better ideas out
there but they didn't know quite where
those ideas were and so they decided to
have an open call so basically what they
did is they release 100 million movie
ratings held back 1.5 million movie
ratings and had a contest for anyone who
could come and predict these held back
ratings so roughly this is what the data
looks like you had a bunch of users you
had a bunch of movies you had some of
the ratings were given and some of the
ratings you had to predict so here this
is different than these human
computation problems because here the
goal of what you're trying to do is
specify but not the task they don't say
run a regression to predict this they
say predict these movie ratings and do
it however you want okay so they offered
a prize of a million dollars and they
open this up to everyone in the world
and then they received close to forty
five thousand submissions now this seems
like horrendous situation so imagine you
getting forty five thousand emails full
of code and crazy whatever and like that
is not what they had to deal with though
so what they they were very lucky
e or very smart or the way this was set
up was very nice which is that it's very
easy for them to check these submissions
all they have to do is just calculate
the root mean squared error it's super
simple so something about the way this
problem is set up enables them to be
open to all these contributions so if
you think lots of social science
problems do not have this structure so
if I like this is like occasionally I
get eat this actually happened this week
I got an email from someone I don't know
who it was is like I've got this cool
thing I've discovered about the
relationship between DNA and language
structure I like that sounds neat and
then like it's like a long thing and I'm
like I guess could be cool but like I
can't read it like I don't have enough
time to read all this stuff but it could
be a great idea and so one of the
beauties of Netflix here is that they
don't have to read all these things they
can find these best ideas really quickly
because they're working with a situation
where solutions are easier to check than
they are to generate so netflix doesn't
know the best way to generate a solution
but if they see is they it's very easy
for them to check a solution once
someone submits it and let me just
illustrate the power of this during the
netflix prize competition this blog post
went up and I want to I showed this in
particular because I want to show you
some about the context of this blog okay
and here is the main idea from this blog
post and I'm just going to read this for
one second so so in other words if we
take a rank 40 singular value
decomposition of the 8.5 billion matrix
we have the best least their
approximation we can within the
generalizable limits of the user movie
rating model etc ie the SVD has found
our best generalization for us pretty
neat a only problem is we don't have 8.5
billion entries we have a hundred
million entries and eight point four
billion empty cells okay there's another
problem to which is the computing the
SVD of a ginormous maître see is well no
fun unless you're into that sort of
thing and then it goes on and on and on
and then it ends so yeah you Matthew
guys are rolling your eyes right now is
it
how short the path was okay so this was
posted by actually was an anonymous
someone who using the screen name sifter
posted this so is this a good idea or is
it not a good idea so some of you
actually probably know how the netflix
prize was solved and know whether this
is a good idea or not but it turns out
that even though this may look like kind
of a strange way of writing up a result
this was a really good idea this moved
them into fourth place in the Netflix
competition which was a huge advance
given that other people in working on
the problem for months and to me this is
so cool this is so different than the
way social science normally happens so
like the number of ideas out there are
really big in social science and we
can't quickly tell which are the good
ideas in which are not the good ideas so
like basically of all the ideas lots of
them never get evaluated and then even
when they do get evaluated they get
evaluated in a bias way because it's
hard to detach the idea from the creator
of the idea I mean we try we have blind
review like and we want to do that but
like when this person uploaded his
contribution to the netflix prize he did
not upload his CV he did not upload the
fact that where he worked or what his
gender was or what his age was like he
just uploaded his predictions for what
movies people would like and then they
were able to very quickly and clearly
see that this was a good idea and so I
wish that there was more ways that as
social scientists we could tap into all
of the good ideas that are out there but
right now we don't have the way this was
set up somehow the way that the
solutions are easier to check are so
easy to check that is a necessary
feature for being able to be open if it
takes a long time to evaluate each
solution then you can't possibly
evaluate all of them so yeah so the key
is that you want problems where the
solutions are very easy to check and
that allows you to really be open to
anything in the world so
now i'm going to give you an example
from social science and try to argue
that this is not just limited to these
kind of prediction kind of tasks so like
you may have seen the netflix process
you've probably seen a lot of other
prizes like that where it's like a
machine learning you think like some
kind of machine learning solution so
this is i'm going to talk a little bit
about peer two patents so this is a
project that was run by the US patent
office which is maybe not a place you
would look for interesting innovation
but actually they had this really neat
system so here's how it works so imagine
that you're a patent examiner and you
get a patent that looks like this so a
here's a little piece of a patent
computer system compromising a processor
basic input/output system include Bob
blah blah blah blah it's like a bunch of
mumbo jumbo and so then you as a patent
examiner have to very quickly figure out
whether this is actually knew or whether
there's prior art and this is a hard job
because as a patent examiner you don't
have very much time you only get about
20 hours per application and it's also
hard because you can't consult with
people outside of the Patent Office so
normally because the patents have to be
secret and so the review process is
necessarily very constrained to ensure
secrecy of the patents and so this
struck Beth Novick whose law professor
is a very strange system and what if you
could have some kind of open like peer
review system for patents that would
help you find the prior art easier and
it would potentially take a lot of the
burden off of the Patent Office so
things could go faster so you get
potentially better and faster so here's
the schematic of how period of patent
works so first a patent applicant has to
opt into this open system and the reason
they would do that is the Patent Office
said we will review all these first you
get to basically jump to the head of the
line of the patent queue which is a very
exciting thing because the patent Q is
very long so then it goes online and a
bunch of a community
fines and uploads potential prior art
then the community goes through a voting
process to produce the top ten pieces of
prior art and then those top ten pieces
of prior art are given to the patent
examiner to evaluate in addition to
whatever review the patent examiner
wants to do so in this way this whole
period of patent process is completely
advisory like the patent examiner is
totally able to just ignore the whole
thing and just do whatever they were
doing before or if there's something
good in this top ten list they can take
it and use it in their decision and so
here again this has a very similar
structure to the netflix prize which is
that once someone out there in the world
find some piece of prior art like this
programmer IBM found some manual from
some Intel device that preceded this
patent and once the patent examiner sees
that it's very easy to check whether
this is yes prior art or no prior art
and so I think there are potentially
more problems than we might realize
there are more problems than just these
like machine learning prediction
problems that might have this easier to
check property and then those then might
be amenable to more open calls where we
potentially elicit solutions from a
large number of people even without
having to know which of those people are
experts or not so again some very simple
claims summarizing what I've said open
calls can produce results better than
experts and I put experts in quotes here
because I think that like the person
that blog post the person who wrote that
blog post even if he is not a professor
at Stanford he is an expert and that he
had this great idea that the people in
Netflix did not have I will also now say
that at that is a not a professor
anywhere he's a software developer at
the time he was doing that he was
backpacking around New Zealand and I
think there's like lots of that stuff
there's lots of great ideas out there if
we could somehow build systems that
allow us to take advantage of them and
then particularly we can access insights
from people that currently aren't
considered experts that actually have a
lot to contribute yeah so few just a few
patents example as a social scientist
example what was the social science
not really social science is closer to
social science I would say that you
could imagine using something like
Pierre de patent in history or in
searching through like archives so a lot
of times you would want to find like
what's the fur is there is there a
mention of certain thing happening in a
certain time period potentially in
settings if if all the relevant
documents are in the same place you
could potentially look through the
archive yourself but imagine like
distributed kind of archive setting you
could think of something like that so
you're right it's not really social
science in the sense like the the
manifesto project was but it's closer to
social science and but I think you've
touched on an interesting point which is
that I don't think there are any I mean
if you know of any please tell me I
don't think there are examples of social
scientists doing open calls yeah almost
distributed data collection do some
suppose your data are like replication
yeah does that count the distributed
data collection is distributed data
collection and that's actually a good
one that I haven't talked about here but
the reason why I don't think it's an
open contest is because it's not about a
solution to some prize that you're some
like criteria that you specified and you
say anyone give me something that
specifies that criteria it's more like
collect this kind of data and
contributed to a bigger project so that
transitions into the distributed data
collection so I want to talk briefly
about ebird which is a super cool
project about ornithology so basically
what happens is there's a lot of people
who like to go and watch birds and it
used to be the case that they would
write they like hip these notebooks and
like they were all just sitting in
people's closets rotting and the these
ornithologists at Cornell said why don't
we just take all these observations that
people are making and even writing down
on paper and aggregate them into this
one giant database of birds so it tries
to take advantage of the work I put work
in quotes because these people actually
enjoy going out and watching birds and
taking notes about it
but the observations that are already
happening and so there they have about
now two hundred thousand participants
have contributed about 250 million
observations this is the case where
again a small number of people
contribute most of the observations and
those people also are higher skill as
best they can tell so it's hard to
actually they have ways of trying to
estimate people skill as a birder from
the data that they have and based on
those estimates they think the people
that contribute the most are also a
highest skill which kind of seems not
implausible but it's actually a little
bit hard to do they have some papers
about that so that's so the but the
problem is that the data from ebert is
really complex to work with so right
identifying Birds is hard and so it's
not clear the quality of the data you're
getting so they have ways around this
they have very elaborate and built up
over time input filter system so like if
I go on uber and report seeing a snowy
egret here in Palo Alto today they're
going to flag that and say there's
that's not possible and then all my
reports go to a expert volunteer like
coordinator from this area who would
then review them and then correspond
with me to get additional information to
verify what I've done so they have a lot
of automatic screening that goes to
these experts so that gets rid of like
pure crazy stuff but there's still you
know who knows then another even
potentially bigger problem is that most
of the observations happen where people
are which is not necessarily where birds
are so if you look in eburg most birds
seem to be near roads and I have a good
idea that there are birds not near roads
and this is the one of the challenges of
getting work that people are doing
anyway is that that work is not
necessarily the work that you want and
then finally as we talked about there's
heterogeneity and observer skill and
there's heterogeneity in the protocols
that they used to do the observation so
it turns out that there's different ways
that you can do birding so you can like
stand in one place and look around you
can walk
or you can like walk in a certain what
you can imagine like if you want to
count the number of birds and a square
acre like there's different procedures
and sometimes people don't follow the
procedures that like an ornithologist
would follow okay but despite these
problems ebert has been used in more
than 200 papers so I think when people
first hear about Eber their first
thought is like oh my god that data it
sounds totally crazy and like that so
the question is is this data perfect no
absolutely not is this beta better than
other available data for certain
questions yes and that is evidenced by
these 200 papers so to give an example a
lot of these papers are about how
climate change has caused change in
migratory arrival times for birds and so
there you could imagine that like just
because you're observing near roads it
doesn't really matter you just need to
know when the arrival time of the birds
is so having this distributed group of
people participating helps you answer
that question so now I want to talk
about another project that's actually a
published in KY presented at KY i think
is like a really cool project and like
really improves on some of the problems
that you could see with ebert or
challenges with you bird so this came
out of this idea like there's this
project called build rome in a day where
they like took a bunch of photos that
people had on flickr and then try to
like conduct create a 3d reconstruction
of rome but really just certain but they
really only had certain of pictures of
certain big touristy sites and so even
those they had only pictures from very
similar angles so it's a little bit like
Ebert in the sense that you're getting
these peoples pictures but they're
really not giving you the pictures that
you want they're giving you the pictures
that they want to give you and so what
if you could somehow kompa the system
that would induce people to collect the
data that you thought was more important
and so that's what I think photo city
dodd did so they had two different
campuses University of Washington and
Cornell and then they tried to in
deuce people to upload photos so that
they could do a reconstruction of the
campus and so they had this game
complicated game mechanics to do that
and then they had about a hundred
thousand photos submitted by about 45
people and they get these kind of
reconstructions so but what I want to
point out is the really beautiful things
about photo city which are I think
especially apparent when you compare it
to ebird so first the data collection
because it's all done with cameras is
standardized so none of this like oh is
this person an expert birder not an
expert birder like camera is a camera
and this I think it looks good for the
future because as more and more of these
observations this distributed data
collection can be done by tools rather
than people that can deal with some of
this variation and observer skill the
verification of these things is
automatic because what would happen so
in eburg you upload that you see a snowy
egret it goes to some expert they have
to check it and then if imagine that i
uploaded something else like I saw a
condor I think I don't know I think you
can see a condor here I don't know but
like it's possible and so be hard to
verify that but so in photo city the
verification is automatic because it
looks to the extent to which your photo
upload overlaps with some existing photo
so it's like a redundant built-in sort
of redundancy checking and it won't
accept photos that don't overlap so
anything that's in there you know
overlaps and then eventually all that
overlap goes back to a few seed photos
that they uploaded so the verification
is built in and then also they have this
really clever scoring system which
causes gives you more points for the
more pixels you add to the
reconstruction and so what they do is
they essentially teach the participants
to upload more valuable data through
this scoring system and so in the paper
they have these great quotes from the
players saying like oh I figured out
that if I go on a cloudy day I should go
to these kind of buildings and on a
sunny day I should go to these other
of buildings and like I walk with my
camera like this so i can take lots of
different pictures to the same time like
they really got much much much better at
collecting the kind of data that the
researchers wanted so i think what what
photo city really shows is that these
things about sampling and data quality
are not necessarily insurmountable
problems especially when we use
technology more so i want to tell you
about another project from social
sciences which is called the malawi
journal project so this was part of a
there was something called the malawi
diffusion ideation change products so
malawi is a country in southern africa
they have a reasonably severe HIV
problem and so this project was set up
to understand how the population thinks
about HIV and how they can you know
reduce the spread of HIV over time so
there's a large like they did surveys
they did collecting health records and
things like that what they also did is
they had 22 journalists write down all
of the comp these are residents of the
area write down all the conversations
they heard people having about HIV and
so over if they've been doing this for a
very long time and now they had this
huge number of pages of text of all
these conversations that people are
having in a natural setting about AIDS
and so what they found which is really
neat is that these citizen journalists
were able to access much different
information than the researchers were
able to access through these standard
survey techniques and that then any sort
of outside Westerner was able to do so
like at the beginning of this project
there was this idea that like AIDS was
like an invisible epidemic and people
didn't talk about it that was the sort
of logic of people coming out of the
World Health Organization and UN aids
and this project should very very
clearly that was not the case there's
tons of people talking about AIDS all
the time they're just not doing it
people coming in from the World Health
Organization and so there's a couple of
other things I like another thing that
that this project showed that was really
interesting was like the way that so
condom use is a good way to prevent the
spread of HIV and there were public
health campaigns about condom use and
one of the things that this showed is
that the way that people talked about
condom use with their friends was very
different than the way that condom use
was framed in the public health messages
so that helps them also understand maybe
why some of their outreach techniques
are not being very effective so coming
to the claims about the distributed data
collection so it's possible for research
sampling and data quality concerns are
not insurmountable and then sometimes it
can produce different and not just
cheaper data like that malawi journal
project data there is no way that Susan
Watkins who was the you know she's a
professor at Penn there's no way that
she could have gotten that data like the
only way to get that data was through
this kind of distributed setting it's
not just about saving money it's also
about getting access to different kinds
of things okay so i had like i have
walked one minute one more minute okay
so i have five design principles that I
think maybe to try to generalize from
these things but I only have one minute
so I'm not going to really be able to
spell them out so first obviously you
really want to motivate your
participants how you do that it's not
clear to you want to be really accepting
of heterogeneity so I think a lot of
times we want to like screen out people
who we think aren't going to be good
enough or something and I think the
heterogeneity is good in open calls it
helps us find novel ideas and in these
other systems it helps create redundancy
that allows for verification so I think
a lot of people don't like heterogeneity
I think heterogeneity is good for these
you want to focus people's attention so
one of the things I loved about photo
city is that it had this system that
basically induced people to do the more
valuable scientific thing and I think
one idea is you just throw it open to
everyone but then you end up wasting a
lot of effort so if you can have some
way to channel all this effort into the
most
meaningful things that's great I think
you also want to enable surprise one of
my favorite things about Galaxy Zoo is
that in addition to labeling the
galaxies which was a task that Galaxy
Zoo was created for the Galaxy Zoo
community also found this new kind of
galaxies the green peas and there's like
this long discussion in the forum about
these and then a professional astronomer
got involved and help them they wrote a
paper about that then there have been
more subsequent papers then just
recently there was a paper in nature
about these green pea galaxies that were
discovered by these people in Galaxy Zoo
then they offered this paper in Nature
was saying that these galaxies are
potential explanation for some kind of
puzzle about ionization in the universe
or something I'm not a I'm not a strong
around totally understand it but the
thing that's cool is that it was
something that was not intended for the
system like Ken if you have a bunch of
people thinking about something and
working on it don't prevent them from
doing other things that are cool too uh
and the last principle is be ethical and
this is like I'm always a true thing to
say but I I think in this space the
ethical standards are still not totally
clear and sometimes people haven't
thought as much about them when they
start to do their work so I would just
say like this something you want to
think about at the beginning and you
want to try to do your best to be aware
of it and so I think I hope that we can
sort of do more cool stuff altogether
thank you
yeah questioning is a text line there's
a love progress right now in semantic
searching and use an app insertion of
these things the thing that you can do
lots of people start generating some
type of life at this base line with
where I'm going is like you're defining
big a different level you got good data
better than that another so you can get
better than that nothing with something
truly like you to these methods you mean
like no sanitation sure join date type
of machine learning yeah no I think
that's that was all very exciting so I
think that in general we don't want to
waste people's time and so if the task
can be done by a computer it should be
done by a computer but I think for the
foreseeable future some of the tasks in
the human computation space at least
some of the tasks that Social Sciences
will want to do are not the machine
learning techniques are not yet totally
available and then I think for open
calls and it's great if someone has a
machine learning technique to do it
great and someone might have an on a
different technique to do it and that's
great and like that's one of the
beauties of those kind of things is that
people can approach them in different
ways and then with distributed data
collection I think yeah that one it's
got to be people doing stuff to get the
data into the system which can then be
analyzed by these other methods yeah
comment that I was just gonna say that
you can avoid a lot of issues that seem
like you're trying to avoid if you try
to
things that are by definition what I
mean by that is a lot of times in
realize you're trying to find out what
someone thinks for you know and if it's
you know if you're measuring personality
and it's what they think of themselves
and their self importance or to be true
by definition something that could
relate to this would be like if you were
actually trying to measure how birds
their distance that birds are two people
changes over time that would be more
provide definition you wouldn't have to
worry though it is this a representative
sample and so you wouldn't have to worry
about like are these people good at
measuring galaxies or something if what
you're actually trying to ask them is
something that could be sure by division
yeah I like that um I don't have to
think more about that but so in general
i like the idea that there are some
tasks that are easier than others for
this kind of approach and I think you're
right that things that are sort of by
definition true should be easier and
then I would have to think more about
what kind of tasks or what kinds of
things fit into that space because a lot
of the things like you mentioned like
personality like that I would think a
lot of it then I think sampling becomes
more of an issue because who you're
talking to potentially it depends what
kind of claims you want to make but my
intuition is that if you're dealing with
these definitionally true things and
sampling becomes maybe more of an issue
but i'm not sure i don't think more
about it basically it's a good idea yep
um and sociologists have to ask it to be
very non quantifiable and my new
non-objective things that you could
never verify with such a like Netflix
missing and if social we'd avoid them
and just go for the
back good skill um say I don't think
that everything is like the netflix
prize in that when you you can sort of
have a clear contest and say one thing
is better than the other i do think that
as sociologists i do think we could do
better at actually having clear
competitions and like being i think that
would spur us to do better thing like
we're sort of like here's one way to
think about this problem here's another
here's another here's another and then
Mike are we really making progress I
don't know that yeah so like this is
kind of how they do it in some machine
learning things where they have like a
core data set everyone tries to do the
same task on the same data set they see
which things work the best and then they
do it again and they do it again and
again and again and over time they get a
sense of like what's actually working
and what's not working and so then when
a new thing happens it's clear whether
that new thing is good or not which is
like to me so cool and it doesn't matter
who you are where you are it's like if
this is the task and this thing doesn't
task well and then we can figure out why
and we can figure out how to make it
better as long as it's much faster to
sort of evaluate than it is to generate
room well just seems like some things
aren't just true or not like if you talk
to quality priscilla this would make
sense so weird so so the milwaukee
journal project that is absolutely
qualitative and they think of that
completely as like a distributed
ethnography and so another way to think
about the distributed so i think the
netflix stuff has that property but like
let's take the period of patent like
there i could say i want to find
examples of personal correspondence
between people that illustrate the theme
of like let's say i argue like love the
modern notion that we have of love is is
it totally new creation and then i say
well can anyone show me an old personal
letter that has the notion of love that
we have today
I mean that's that's something you could
imagine doing an open call for more
ancient version of this right is we have
different theories about love yeah thing
like this you know eventually is it's
gonna be better and she's a larger
mindshare but i disagree i think
citations are not a good i mean i think
like my lesson that i draw from the
music experiment is that that like
basically people's attention is very
limited and they focus on things that
are already popular and then those
things become more popular and a lot of
good stuff gets lost yeah thnkx is
suitable on so the so the big question
this raises for me is about professional
status yeah mom so as as data science
sort rolls into the sciences you can
imagine sort of a range of different
sort of like sort of jurisdictional
defenses so you spoke a little bit about
sociologists being sort of skeptical at
the Palladium yeah seems to have any
sort of observations about how different
sciences are sort of responding
interesting I think um so i think uh
ornithology i think is more accepting
because they have a long tradition of
this this goes back a long time in
ornithology like hundreds of years so to
them it doesn't seem weird i think part
of it is that a lot of the concerns
people have in my mind are not very
specific they're just like because it's
weird i mean like let's be honest like
some of the stuff is like very different
than what people are used to and it's
appropriate to be cautious right and
skeptical and so I think like what I
hope is that we move beyond that first
just blanket skepticism to more specific
questions like oh well is there a
correlation between amount of data
contributed and skill and then we can
like like make progress in a kind of a
normal way and I do think the thing
about professionalization and status is
a is a concern and I think I wish it
wasn't but like actually so it's
interesting so when I talk to a student
a graduate student about this
about the open calls and she was like so
what is the researcher do then like
you're not really solving the problem
and I'm like no that's like you're like
a huge contribution to like pose the
problem correctly and motivate a whole
community of people to work on it like
that's I think what thinking about what
research impact is is not like about
solving specific problems but changing
the way people think and getting people
excited about new things so I think in
some ways like this is a just posing the
right question and organizing the right
kind of system even if you're not doing
the bits and pieces of the work is an
enormous contribution that you can be
making to science
you